hello and welcome to this video play max
power from Denmark try to take 2500
again window the last game is more like
like 1500 okay I'm taking this is an
interesting line that I always wanted to
study a little bit more also from the
legs point of view but I keep keep
forgetting to do that yeah I think I
actually thought that this wouldn't work
and due to this and the check and check
this is something that happened to me
with black in a game and it was rather
embarrassing yeah because you have to
play this um I think it is really as bad
as it looks but it we'll see we'll see
what happens ok so a 3 here or queen
queen bee three also comes into
consideration probably and the Queen
wolf
look there okay so go if for okay I'm
let's develop
I try to consciously play more
prophylactically think more about the
opponent's options but this can
sometimes be a tricky approach in blitz
because it takes time to yet tried to
figure out what the other guy wants to
do and sometimes you just don't have the
time in a blitz game yeah currently my
main goal it would be fantastic let's
say if I get an A for move the bishop
play b5 that would be end of game but
it's probably difficult to achieve I try
to open up the center instead this king
is not exactly safe mmm is not see for
good and difficult i am now right to
avoid this may I should've taken on a
fire first but I saw this and I felt
that I should head for this straightaway
ok I'm these six I can go d6 actually
Bishop d6 Queen d3 check ok ok ok Bishop
f5 it's not not decisive
hmm how to do that should be six check
we should have five it is good that is
good but I wonder if it's the best I
just go Rupe do you wanna Bishop t6
takes take screen before this should
actually be quite convincing threatening
t6 if he goes Bishop t6 I take and take
on reform this should and actually push
the pawns home I wrote the eight though
maybe rope the aid and no it's it's also
pretty good and it's a technical
technical way of playing it but it
should be sufficient to seven office
immediately
still cannot take on a 2-1 do anything
with the rooks I want to go Rupe 22 King
f2 and then activate ok you cannot take
so i think i can bring the keynote yeah
just hook before i guess not no i can
actually go here the King on f3 check
yep that's gained the space King King
coming to the floor
okay so probably here for King to see 5
the ruckus is basically trapped black
resigns yeah I think I actually fell
into the same opening trap myself a
while ago in and over the board blitz
tournament yeah you know maybe knight c6
but I'm sorry it was the wrong button I
think Josh just doesn't work and
position is just not playoff with the
chemo d7 I think I wasn't in precisely
the same situation in that in that blitz
tournament and I got duly killed yeah
and now opening up the center it just
lost for black I mean of course and why
it can can screw up but it is a losing
position it would have been easier here
if I would've taken actually I was a bit
too quick and taking and because i saw
this which which which is nice but still
the other continuation was probably
similar time ya hear that i just went
for the winning ending which maybe we
could have been could have could have
wanted quicker but well one way is
definitely enough that who along in that
he plays here it is interesting will see
5 and but i think that'd be six is just
not not well timed if you take and play
b6 the same thing is actually in a fact
jack yeah it'sit's maybe even worse so
he has to do something else here maybe
maybe knight c6 comes into consideration
then what the player should be five it's
a very strange position looks a little
like the the notable there
the Queens gambit semi slob but okay
it's closed reverse and distribution 184
it's very very unconventional okay well
thanks for watching